hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Endo parasitic I am
ready oh I almost did the exact same
thing I did before but I was ready this
time and I now know that it goes boom
boom boom boom so long as I keep it to
that it should be okay
yeah the very notion they'd pick her
over me
how Thane how clueless
[Music]
how vain how stupidless how unsmartitude
I can't believe the wherewithout or the
wherewith all this is ridiculous
it can't be oh boy
oh boy
oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
that's how I do I don't know how you
guys do but I do like that
welp oh crap
I just had a funny feeling that if I
encountered that thing while I was in
there I would uh
probably not survive oh God I'm not
going to survive I'm not going to
survive
I survived
thanks pal thank you
oh boy
oh yeah boy
you couldn't have killed that dude
all right
interesting
whoa oh you your boy your boy your boy
oh whoops
your boy
oh
yo boy yes
your boy did good
but this thing is going towards my brain
oh wait well both that's what you get
wait did you get what you get did you
actually get what you get
I don't think he got what he got
I don't think he got what he was
supposed to get I think I might have
goofed it
die because I'm not gonna have enough
time
to do what needs to be done whoa yeah
boy what is your boy's deal oh
crap crap
crab baskets I am running out of
crossbow bolts crap
please tell me you opened something with
God damn it oh man where's my other
crossbow bolt whoa
I don't even know
oh God I'm gonna lose that forever if I
don't pick it up
holy crap oh now you're you're done so I
can go through the tight space hopefully
there oh I'm not gonna make it oh I
didn't get the thing oh I'm not gonna
make it oh I'm Not Gonna Save because I
don't know what I'm doing oh God oh God
oh God okay
yep
please don't spawn again
please don't spawn again
okay we're doing okay here my friend
so long as you don't spawn again
okay whoa
what
I'm done
well that's not good
all right so we're in a slightly better
situation than we were but still not
very good
oh yeah I forgot
okay or I can just flub it super hard
okay
I think it doesn't spawn in here because
it's too enclosed of space
so I'm actually probably okay while I'm
in here oh no I'm not oh you missed me
you missed ah
why would you do that glad I handled
that appropriate situation like a fully
grown adults
really amazing
showcasing my maturity this is
interesting oh fascinating well
touche
maybe even whoa you can spawn an ear
interesting
man this guy kind of blows ass
and let me tell you I know a thing or
two about blowing ass don't ask me out
don't ask me why I will never expand on
that ever ever
why would you do that why would you go
oh kill me
Manny freaking spawn killed that dude
no not that come on
you know what I want to do so do it
oh God
new son of a [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
you son of a [ __ ]
what are you gonna do
jokes on you
haha I tried to put a bolt in my brain
oh hey bud error
no oh God
that was not worth it oh are you kidding
me are you kidding me
air air
great great this was so worth it oh hey
bud
hey how you doing bud I'm just gonna do
this
or not
or not interesting thank you holy [ __ ]
this is an ideal on ideal on ideal on
ideal unideal unideal oh god
oh man Lexi and Skip past this part and
make me look good make me look so good
maybe you look really handsome
wait a minute
wait a minute
put this up just gonna do that oh hey
buddy
okay you're dead
good wow okay I opened wow okay
man I am dodging it I'm dodging it my
dudes I'm dodging it my dudes
I'm out of here is this out of here
all right I'm the best I'm the best
those were all Victory screeches all of
them every one of them I am so good
God damn
that was the most skilled gameplay I've
ever executed in my life I may have lost
a crossbow bolt but it is chill it is
cool it is totally fine I am extremely
happy with that level of gameplay that I
exuberated
[Laughter]
over rounds I love being back in the
revolve revolver family
because this is really where the top
tier gameplay actually has always been
is the revolver gameplay I believe that
revolver only is the truest way that
this game was meant to be played
Brim
here it is your problem dear
trying to close reindeer Goods whoa hey
bud do a Shadow Demon
interesting
[Music]
love this
kill it
okay or
well I got him after the fact but at
least they're gotten
hello and I have another one of these
which is all good
all right well well oh man I hope that
save game doesn't always open like that
that'll be uh awfully inconvenient for
me
all right good enough
how long does it take to start to choose
charge up its save juice
uh interesting
I seem to have lost another crossbow
from Juan Square I know not
can I save please save juice
please I really want that save juice
God I really hope the safe juice gets oh
please you're so close come on you're
right there come on come on there we go
okay go
wait
man it sure was actually killing you
worked
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh please tell me you
killed me
yeah
all right
this is where the skills pay the bills
oh God I thought I thought maybe well
all right interesting that is good
though I think
use this to my advantage
yes yes do those things yes be that for
me yes my puppet my
oh you are my play thing
please open these for me friend
whoa all right that's from
[Music]
I thought there was a wasn't there a rat
oh the rat is dead
I see
whoa too close too close
well damn now I'm starting this next
area with so much goodie
oh this is
you should be dead I'm more alive than
I've ever been you're the one who let
the parasites out I can't believe it I
didn't want to believe it for as smart
as you think you are you've been putting
this together a little slow for my taste
I let the parasites out because they
asked me to they wanted to make me their
God not you all I had to do was let them
flourish how could they pick you out of
everyone you half-witted vapid ignorant
you're the ignorant one sent you've been
being dedicated to your work
worshiping knowledge and valuing science
over others lives and happiness makes
you above everyone else you're not above
me you're not above pravi you're not
even above the Lab Rats you're a moral
unethical you have no Compass no virtues
and you haven't even got the
self-awareness to care without feeling
you're nothing
that's why they picked me
this universe has too many men like you
oh well how many of them have only won
our world what's happening what's this
about
oh I'm slippy slidey
I'm unstoppable
I'm mobile
you think that you know me you think
you've bested me what's this about I'm
detecting a weak spot here
yes yeah oh God okay a yes you will
expose your weakness to me
you fool I should probably do things
[Music]
what's all this then you think that you
know just because you actually care
about people oh you wouldn't know the
first thing
fingerping
you you make me sick or something
[Music]
oh okay Lucy
Lucy
yes you think that your science can stop
you me me you I mean you think that your
lack of science can stop the me that is
you what am I saying well two can
science that game
you fool oh missed me now you must kiss
me I will show you the true power of a
kiss of science
you wish you could feel love
morals caring for your fellow man
I will show you the true power
well apparently revolve around do
nothing
your lack of science does nothing to
move my
heart well this should be working by now
oh
I'm Gonna Make You attack your own thing
oh wait it's not even this one wait am I
dumb
no I'm not dumb science is on my side
how does your science answer why I'm
laughing so hard
you
where are you you're still up there how
are you still there
take that science not the opposite I
speak in riddles you couldn't even
understand
ow
oh
man that hurt
or did it
or or did it or or did it
oh
where'd you come from Big Boys
well this is a conundrum uh how do it
well
um uh oh interesting
fascinating even wow you didn't kill any
of your friends
oh my goodness
this is a problem
this is a problem Oh this is a problem
[Music]
this is a problem interesting
um well uh I uh uh uh
interesting
I got boxed in
not gonna lie that wasn't a good look
for me but joke's on you I'm always good
looking Lucy taste my gun you're not
there are you damn you
maybe I should go around yeah I should
probably collect the vaccine before I
get too deep into this fight
[Music]
oh ah right yep
oh interesting
wow
wow wow wow
oh whoa what the hell is happening
no rats God damn you rats
what is this got him what
foreign
ers
I have it
I just have to oh
that's not what I wanted to do but
that'll clear some space Oh [ __ ] okay ah
[ __ ]
oh frick uh this
okay that's that was that was extremely
unfair thank you
yes give me a path no
oh that's two of those I need I need
those no not a rat not a rat not a rat
oh God please give me this okay okay
this is my chance this is my shots my
shot I gotta get through oh god there
goes my shot
oh man that was my chance okay I gotta
reload this please no
no I was wrong
don't worry ah you think that you think
that you think you think
have you ever thought a thought in your
life that wasn't because of science
I need to get rid of this
oh God whoa
ah
you think that you're foolish enough to
fool me Fool's on you I've never been
fooled a day in my life don't you know
who I am I'm
sinte my name will be remembered forever
forever
forever
take this you fool oh
take this you fool
but
take take this you fool oh wait
I'm detecting something
take this you fool you fool why are you
not foolishly fooling yourself
you should be fully fooled at this point
well you
[Music]
okay okay
you fool you've Fallen right into my
trap
oh my God whoa oh whoa okay that's
interesting
oh my God
oh my God
all right oh God no oh no I'm stuck why
am I okay
wow okay did you take two on this
okay so I think the answer is I need to
make sure I destroy these things when
they appear
and I definitely get enough bullets to
Warrant doing that I just have to make
sure it clears down because if I don't
then I'm gonna be in trouble later
okay
[Music]
yeah because if I don't do that I'm
gonna get overwhelmed and I'm gonna get
boxed in and it's gonna be game over
so no matter what I gotta make sure I do
that
there's gonna be certain pacing that's
gonna make sure that I can't
oh God and then that's why I need to
make sure but hey
I get vaccines
that's another reason to do that and
plenty of bullets
so I'm never gonna be at a loss for
bullets so long as I'm doing some damage
on the guy
oh and that's why I don't reload
afterwards
good good understood understood I'm I'm
starting to get it
oh is that a flare oh my God that's
flare gun rounds holy [ __ ] okay that's
good that's gonna be incredibly useful
I'm gonna make sure I can get that
[Music]
we're going
[Music]
just load it up good
okay so I should have enough space to do
one of these and then let it grow again
good
starting to really get a feel for it
okay I need to clear out some space
oh really all those shots and I didn't I
didn't hit the freaking thing one the
rat once
[Music]
really really wow
oh God that's being boxed in
that is a box
okay Now's the Time to use this I think
not that this
oh I dodged that
[Music]
cleared out a whole bunch of stuff but
even so I still want to make sure I get
this flare I've got no two
all right let's get this
that's good
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go
it's good keep myself healthy
shotguns
oh God damn it well it killed that guy
partly good
where are you at low Health
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no you do not do this to me
okay
somehow that did good
just do this again
okay somehow that worked
I need help I need there had to have
been a health somewhere here right right
no
sadly nope it looks like a no big fat no
last one I think
that's how we do it yep
yep yep okay with a little patience with
a little progress with a little
skill holy crap we did it that was
intense
but I did it and I showed you Lucy
that's what you get normal you can
detention tunnel compromise
Communication System offline
I'll have to get to the spacecraft
before she does or I'll be stuck here
yeah I'll definitely get there in time
definitely wasn't caught up killing
things I won't kill you scent
parasite will do a fun enough job of
that
you're going to leave me here why not
isn't that what she would do
good luck scent may payurite have mercy
on you who's pyera day
well you don't even need the spacecraft
oh
oh well
I guess
oh but I was just getting into it but I
was just getting good oh but I just
found my skills
[Music]
oh what's the making of oh oh okay so
it's just a series of YouTube videos but
you can do that let me see this what
achievements have I gotten here beat the
game on hard mode kill a corpse trap did
I do that I haven't beaten the game on
hard mode
hard so if I'm not mistaken in the very
beginning of this it wasn't three other
random people that ripped my limbs off
it was the monsters themselves it is the
monsters
right
get back here get back here I see what a
fun game what a fun game so I'm not
gonna go through it again on hard mode
it's all fine research here I have to
end the evacuation orders really do you
think now this time now now that I'm
seeing the beginning of it again it
really does seem quite silly the fact
that uh it was like so committed to
continuing the research the research
everybody the research the race sure
instead of you know
uh getting any sort of understanding of
the situation as it is but no anyway
good game I like that a lot I really
really like that I don't know how it
continues but the theme of it the idea
behind it and some of the
some of the gameplay just very very fun
anyway go watch the making of you can
find it um on the measies YouTube
channel
very good they have quite a lot of views
too how to make a horror Survival game
in two days no way
no way very cool oh
a visible Crosshair would have been
incredibly useful oh man if I had a
visible Crosshair you mean when I like
shoot and stuff oh that would have been
so useful
oh visible crosshairs would have helped
so much oh I can see where I shoot
oh man that would have been nuts
well it sure looked like I was shooting
right at you but whatever it's fine
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching this really a fantastic game
really very fun well polished fun to
play I highly recommend it and I can't
wait for a sequel thank you and as
always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]